[Music]
today's question comes from tim in
pennsylvania
i have a 16 year old son that does
nothing but play video games he seems to
think he will be a rich youtuber how do
i motivate him
it's a big one i feel like this
generation i've heard a lot of kids
recently saying they want to be a
youtuber and i think it kind of falls
into two buckets like saying i want to
be an influencer
shoot me you failed as a parent
oh my gosh
but i will say there are people doing
youtube so yeah and there are people
doing influencing
not anything to be proud of though but
before you come down on him i would see
if there are some nuggets there that
could be a career so does he potentially
like videography does he like
engineering is there some type of design
work that could interest him so dig into
that and you know see
is there something in that space now if
you start pushing him to explore
different options and he's not
interested in that
then it might truly be a motivation
problem but i would first see if there
are any nuggets of some sort of career
path that might be in there that's not
just being an influencer or a youtuber
yeah there's something i mean you you
you know we're on youtube and we make a
lot of money on youtube so you can make
money on youtube i'm not saying that
um and i guess in a sense in a weird
kind of a way we're influencers except
we really do stuff and have actual
thoughts we're not just famous for being
famous
but the um
but
here's the thing tim the way i would
approach it is this
um
i would take him
somewhere away from your house
coffee at a minimum
camping would be better
and uh just say my job
as your dad
is to prepare you for adulthood
to turn you into a good adult
a good adult has a good understanding
that work
is where money comes from
so my job as your dad is to teach you to
work
i have failed and i'm sorry for that
because i've allowed you to sit in the
basement and play video games that's not
work
and so you're going to start learning to
work
the bad news is i've messed up the worst
news is you're about to learn to work
you're going to start doing some things
where you learn how to work because i
don't want you being 38 years old living
in my basement
so you're going to learn how to work i
love you too much to allow you to think
that playing video games is an actual
job
it's not
it's what you do for fun it's a cool
hobby
it's exhilarating
but it is not an actual job
and so i'm gonna help you learn to work
now part of that might be
the nice things that christina was
saying because i'm an old dinosaur dad
and she's a nice lady
so uh but the nice part of the part of
that is part of that is i think you may
be drawn to something like video work
you might be drawn to something that has
something to do with the gaming world or
the youtube world and i'm fine to help
you explore some of that let's uh let's
get a camera
and let's see if you can actually make
some money doing this
and let's do let you know maybe make
some money that's not on youtube
and not have to do with a video game but
still has to do with those those same
kinds of skills and discover some of
those skills help him discover some of
those skills and and you know scratch
the itch that he's got if it is a
creative itch
if it is not a i want to sit on my butt
itch
because some because some of these
people do want to sit on their butt when
they're 16. most of us did by the way
some of us just had fathers that
wouldn't allow it and mothers that
wouldn't allow it
and so i mean your mother would jacked
you up if you come in saying that oh
yeah oh yeah my mom is a challenger and
she would have
nothing to do with that but yeah i mean
she she would have been more like me
than you oh
you were like let's discover his gifts
and i'm like kick his butt you know but
i mean
but both of them have the same
motivation both answers are how do we
help the child not what tim wants but
what he wants for his son i want my son
to become a man
right men
work
right and it's a loving challenge like
it is a challenge that is a challenge
like we're not going to tolerate sitting
around playing video games like that's
off the table the grown-ups i shouldn't
say men grown-ups work let's just call
it that okay and so yeah you find your
gifts the bible talks about train up a
child in the way he is old in in the way
he is molded or the old king james says
in the way he is bent
and the way is bent the way he's
designed train up a child in the weight
so that's what you're saying pull those
gifts out start using them but you know
sitting around saying i really have no
plans in life because i want to be a
youtuber this is not a plan young man
this is not a plan this is a good way to
end up broke
and so you've got to have um you got to
have something more than that but dig in
dig in dig in
and do take him out of the house this is
not sitting in his bedroom or your
bedroom or the living room he's got to
be away from the house this is a mono
imano a man on man
discussion i am your dad i love you so
much i'm going to help you become a man
my son absolutely this question reminds
me a lot of when people talk to me about
their kids not wanting to go to college
some people get really negative about
that right away they think oh my gosh my
kids are going to fail they didn't go to
college and it's like that's not the
case they just may have interests that
don't lie within the realm of college so
maybe talk to them about a trade program
talk to them about a vocational program
like really lean into their interests
and see what they are but bottom line
we're not gonna sit at home and eat
cheese puffs all the time like you're
gonna do something well you know why
they call them starving artists
because they don't make much art
you know yeah and so if you but there
are plenty of artists that make a lot of
money right because they create a lot of
art
you know you know why they call them
starving songwriters because they don't
write a lot of songs
but i've got friends who are in
nashville who've written a thousand two
thousand songs and if i said their name
you would know their name
tada they saw a lot of songs but there's
a work ethic involved in the creative
process you don't sit around and wait on
roast duck to fly in the window you go
shoot the duck
pluck the duck and cook the duck this is
where duck comes from you know it
doesn't just fly in the window already
roasted and so this is the lesson that's
missing in this question
right right i think that a lot of times
this question of how can i be a youtuber
it's because the kids are saying the
glamorous side of youtube they're saying
you know an influencer and that's cool
but it's like no you got to be willing
to do the work
man i'm telling you the people that make
it on i mean we've had a billion
downloads on this podcast the people
that make it in the podcast world they
work
we show up here every day
three hours a day doing this and we like
it we have fun doing it but
you know most people don't understand
that that's how that's where this comes
from
so what
malcolm gladwell calls and outliers 10
000 hours of practice
before you're successful and it may
involve doing a whole lot of stuff
that's not on youtube before you get
there